I said I wanna come where I'm at any
better care to brothers and sisters and
dear friends hope you guys are well
inshallah welcome to this video now
we're gonna be discussing a very
disturbing topic as you guys saw on the
title we were talking about man called
Reinhardt synagogue
so this is Indonesian man born of a
Christian family raised in a Christian
occult and he went to the church was
somebody that was involved in church
deeply would be somebody that reads the
Bible
now you're gonna think him why are you
telling us about his faith well there's
a few reasons why I'm telling you guys
about his faith number one this man has
raped about a hundred and ninety six men
yeah be heard it when we heard hear the
word rape it's usually a synonym to you
know kind of woman in a woman get raped
you know but in this case it's men he's
actually reached 196 men God knows for
how long he would be studying in the
news Indonesia he decided to come to
Manchester and what he did and the way
he preyed on his victims is that he will
find men in Manchester who were drunk
half drunk you no doubt that tipsy but
they're in the verge of being drunk he
will get them to go to his house now as
a man you know that's a bit weird you
know you're drunk we still have some of
your faculties there but you can clearly
see that he took advantage of them he
took them to his house and sets them up
you can sleep here
you know until you wake up and then he
would give them a special formula yeah
he would give them this special formula
that they would drink and they would
literally pass out yeah and from there
onwards he does whatever he wants to
them literally whatever he wants to them
and what's really crazy is that when he
was being trialed he said that because
how they found out about this was that
they went to his flat and they found a
bunch of phones and in these phones they
saw him actually video recording it from
different angles and I know even what
angle he's recorded from different
angles to him and he said to his mother
his own mother that this was like some
kind
a documentary for him yeah and it just
shows you how sickening and how
disgusting you must be you know to
actually do this now how did he get
caught here's a little video footage of
what happened and how we ended up
getting caught in 2007
you
so as you guys saw in that video his
last victim a young man if I'm not
mistaken seventeen-year-old woke up and
spot this guy if I'm not mistaken yeah
so literally matched his face up yeah
like blood everywhere and you know
apparent when his mom saw him and his
mom was outraged because of what
happened to him like what the hell was
you expecting to happen you know how
could somebody issue saying you know he
was unmatched in the fight you know a
big white man was beating up this little
you know miskeen come on now let's go
back to the first point that I mentioned
196 men being raped raped just imagine
if that was a Muslim raping a bunch of
women or men or whatever you wanna call
it now what is more crazy is that the
LGBT and all the alphabets that may
follow community has said something
outrageous just imagine as Muslims if we
was to say something like this year this
is what they said they said the
following i quote synagogue did not did
not say so but one fact that may have
been his country's attitude towards
homosexuality as recently as 2014 the
northern province of akka or h ax passed
a law to punish anyone caught having gay
sex with 100 lashes so what this
community seen is the following if where
he lived indonesia did not have this
punishment 100 and lashes to homosexuals
yeah or you know someone commits in sex
outside of marriage yeah
or to single people commands in ER this
man would have not done that now this
guy this evil perpetrator who has raped
one hundred and ninety six men recorded
it filmed it in court says that they
were you know he said he said they were
playing a part they were pretending to
be asleep
they were pretending it was an active
pretend to be asleep while i was raping
them and they just ashamed of it you
know they loved what I was doing to them
yeah and some of them his victims men
tried to commit suicide
this is imagine as a man being violated
in that way you wouldn't want to live
you would not want to be a life is
disgusting so we need to firstly
highlight that these things happen to
men as well you know because sometimes
it's always you know woman would know
these things happen to men as well
imagine you have a Muslim man a Muslim
man goes and rapes a bunch of woman or
whatever it may be
yeah I imagine that the grooming issue
that has been happening yeah this is a
devout Christian man by the way those
Muslim men who were doing this one not
devout they would not devote that they
were living the western lifestyle of
carbon drinking partying and bringing
these girls giving them drugs etc
imagine if I came and said hmm
we think as the Muslim community the
reason why these men have raped these
groom these innocent young girls the
reason they've done it is because in
their country in Afghanistan or Pakistan
or whoever country you wanna this this
punishment for adultery
you know I was think that's the reason
why they raped this many girls can you
imagine the uproar can you imagine what
will happen if I personally said that my
unfinished janaza yeah night-night boom
I'm gone I'm finished
but the LGBT community can casually just
come and say oh he's you know he makes
him a victim and be that you know the
reason why he did that was because
there's hundred lashes for my sexuals in
Indonesia
well those hundred lashes would be
implemented on this man or more for
raping men who are drunk and taking
advantage of them you see that's the
reason why promises in Islam Allah
subhana WA Ta'ala is legislated a
certain law to protect the rights of the
community as a whole rather than an
individual by himself
the reason why for example these men
were drunk I'm not gonna blame them
obviously if you wasn't drunk you would
not be in that situation you know you
would have fights him off somehow
but it shows you the Sharia the Islamic
law that's in place it's there to
protect a community as a whole
prevention is better than cure and we
see this over and over again every 90
seconds in the Western world
a woman is subject of some kind of a
rape catcalling being treated like
degraded animals
one-night stands I was reading some kind
of a study showing that some women are
suicidal but they meet a man they they
are they want to be with him as
you know their life with him and he just
wants one-night stands yep we live in a
corrupt society and this is now slowly
slowly coming to the Muslim community
now these things could relate to each
other brothers and sisters Islam has
come to protect the community as a whole
and that's that's the reason why certain
punishments are there as a deterrent
because Islam is come to preserve five
things the wealth the health the lineage
the religion and one more thing that I
can remember and yeah another thing like
remember this content to protect those
five things yeah that's the reason why
it's an honor I think the other honor
that's the reason why there's severe
punishments on these topics yeah so when
it's come for the lineage the punishment
of stoning why because it's there to
protect the family unit it's a deterrent
it's so hard it's a deterrent you don't
want to go there yeah it's going to
protect your wealth why the person who
steals their hands will be amputated why
because it's not just anyone we're
talking about in an Islamic society
where it's established everyone's living
in a wealthy system not corrupt people
who are stealing the money once you're
in that system and you're living in
harmony and peace you have no excuse to
steal and investor if you're stealing
then you're in trouble and there's a
whole condition besides that etc yeah
and for example to preserve the religion
that's why there is loss for example
that if somebody leaves their religion
yes there is some capital punishment
it's a similar thing to treason yeah
similar finsihed reason and there's a
bigger discussion on it yeah these
things and the rest is well there's
severe punishments why for example the
owner slander why slander God have to
punish me why because it's the owner of
a woman that's why Sudan allows France
out of review I know why because I
should rather and her was slandered you
know so these things are in place to
protect the community as a whole and to
stop men like him that's why the article
says Senecas convictions make him the
most prolific rapist tried in Britain
and possibly any quote in the world
except there was one other guy called
Raji Obara a Korean Japanese sex
criminal is thought to have raped
between 150 and 400 woman
but was only convicted of nine guys it's
a disgusting attack we did not you know
nobody blame this religion but the
reason I mention is religion in the
beginning was to just highlight the
issue if this was a Muslim man doing
this we would be blaming Oh we'll be
blaming Islam and this and that but
right now as you can see what makes me
most it makes it more sickening and
disgusting is that the far-right choose
and pick you know it's it's sad it's
like saying you know what I prefer to
talk about this because I want to use it
to my advantage and propaganda this I'll
turn a blind eye so they don't really
have an issue with young girls being
raped or being groomed you know or
pedophiles doing certain things their
issue is with the religion itself but
we're not gonna do that we're not gonna
come and say this is a Christian
Christian problem even though we have
every right we can say you know hold on
a second these are devout men priests
you know we can say these are deva
devoted men to their faiths to christ
without carrying out these attacks but
we're still not gonna do that because we
believe that christians he doesn't teach
these things so guys i'm sure you guys
will disturb it as much as I was but
we've learned a lot of things in this
specific case and we pray for their
victims because it's disgusting some of
them are suicidal
and we ask for them to be recovered
mentally from this scenario inshallah
and this man is actually has no remorse
in prison he had absolutely no remorse
what a disgusting man that deserves a
life sentence of 30 years and inshallah
he never comes out and hopefully he
turns back to his lord allah subhanaw
taala asks for forgiveness for his
disgusting crimes for me above and Odawa
til next time
assalamu alaikum what I'm trying there
care to